for all three of you
if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
um
steve
what do we think
what do we think uh
let's let's take this whole interview to
think about it um
the after party
party's pretty good i mean yeah the
after
should we all right i'm just gonna throw
something out i'm gonna throw out a
project that i i am involved in that i
love the project is 21 jump street which
relates to after party because same same
got creators all that stuff um
i love jump street these these guys are
they're geniuses um the fact that they
they pulled off that movie based on this
old tv series and kind of reinvented it
and made it this whole new thing and um
you know they're doing something similar
with the after party bringing it around
uh
uh where they're creating this uh this
really unique structure that we've never
really seen before where every episode
is a different genre you guys go
yeah dude
that was very impressive that was very
impressive thank you thank you um uh uh
i will say if someone's never seen
something i've done i would probably
show them the movie blockers um
[Music]
but the thing is this it's like it's
it's
it really is just a prelude to the after
party
which is interesting really interesting
transition people yeah yeah i'd be like
oh you want you you check me out take a
look if you like it oh you like it watch
the after party
i like that
yeah what i would say is i
this is the only work i've ever done
the after writing so i hope it's the
aftermarket because i always be after
ready um i don't know i i don't know i
really i did a tv show called love life
that was really fun um
yeah
some other i like that answer you're
you're amazing in that show yeah thanks
dave uh so i've seen the first seven
episodes of the after party it's so good
chris and phil are um what we call
talented um
uh what on what day though of the shoot
did the continuity person say f this and
rage quit
it's so funny you know
we this is complex to say the least and
we are just kind of dumb actors uh but
god bless chris miller's brain um
he has been sitting with us in his head
for
a decade and and thought of so many
twists and turns and
had it so clearly mapped out in his
brain and had such a great team
surrounding him that
there was never a moment and this is
complex like i said like you should have
seen one way
then you're gonna come up and shoot that
same scene
you know totally different pov
totally different genre
your character now completely changes
because of what they think
and
we were there was not a minute where i
was lost or like wondering wait what's
happening it was so seamless and so
smooth and it
that allowed us time to actually kind of
improvise a little bit
and just kind of try stuff because chris
had
so
just mapped everything out and made it
so clear to us so
uh the continuity person luckily
kind of phoned it in quite frankly no
i'm joking they worked really hard
like no way
which which of you guys i don't know who
the killer or killers in the series is
are i have no idea but which of you
correctly guessed
who
who it maybe was
did any of you correctly guess it
we all got to read the scripts when we
signed on and
so i don't know we never had this
discussion i didn't actually i was so
engrossed in the scripts that i
i don't know if i ever
ventured to guess i was shooketh when i
found out and then when we shot it uh
over five months you know shot it
towards the end of our shoot i was
shaken again because at that point we
had really become attached to these
characters and didn't really want anyone
to be guilty
um
so
yeah
i normally uh gauge things by what my
wife thinks and she guessed it was four
different people when she watched it
so
and i i was very frustrated with me when
i wouldn't tell her along the way so
that's that's a good uh
i i asked i i watched it with my wife as
well and i asked her after every episode
who do you think it is and she changed
her answer every single day yes yes yes
that way they have their they're covered
they've inoculated themselves by
guessing wrong because they asked right
so will you just guessed everyone
what do you think you're better than me
i love the way that each episode you
touched on it a little bit but i love
how each episode is a different genre
and the way it's shot like you sometimes
in an action movie or you're in an
animated
like it's it's really hard to do what
chris did with this and i'm just curious
did you guys have a favorite genre that
was not like the one that focused on you
if you know what i mean
yeah
we were talking we
yeah we all
really dug um episode five uh which was
the throwback
uh high school party
um it was really fun to meet everybody
as their younger selves and
dave looked incredible
uh and
watching ike navigate his wig was a
comedy and it's also
that was that episode was um
which was probably the hardest i laughed
in the whole show was dave and sam's
fight
um
which was
out of the front lawn of this house and
it was like at midnight it was very cold
outside
and
covid was just
ravaging the globe and the world was on
fire and i was sitting there like like
hyperventilating i was laughing so hard
at these two guys just being absolute
just climbing trying to trying to put
the
lamest fight of all time on the lamest
it was like a twyla tharp composition
like dance
yeah
i don't understand the reference
it was weird modern dance it was modern
art it was weird modern art what youtube
did it was not a fight
but i i thought i was going to have a
heart attack
that fight is it had me laughing out
loud i watched the seven episodes as i
said yesterday um how how much is that
choreographed and how much is that like
you guys just you know what i mean
zero choreography
yeah truly we just started it just got
crazier and crazier every take and
eventually we just started dancing at
each other and
[Music]
but yeah the the in the back of our head
it was like the lamer this is the better
this is yes definitely definitely
i loved uh the jasper episode just
because the music the songs in the
episode are so good um and i'm just
curious what you guys thought about the
basically the musical episode and what
ben pulled off
great episode
and the music is so good also xavier's
songs are so good like they legit
bop
yeah and the ben man i was in one of the
ben musical videos and it
ben is the energizer bunny like it like
he got up and did this entire number
and like if i did that twice i would be
like
all right i'm gonna i need some pure
oxygen and we gotta take about a three
hour we're gonna shut down about three
hours
and i'm gonna like get into like an ice
chamber
um ben did it like 15 16 times in a row
just kept going all i had to do was
stand and play guitar and he was just
like it was it was incredible it was
very very very impressive to watch could
not have done that but the music the
music and the show in general it's like
obviously the lyrics some of the lyrics
are funny but
they're good songs you can't help but
just bob your head to it yeah
no a hundred percent every everyone on
this show i'm sure can make everyone
else laugh so who was the one who ended
up ruining the most takes because they
could not keep it together
this is where you throw someone under
the bus i mean i don't want to say she
ruined takes but like
alana glazer was
like very pr was pregnant when we were
shooting it and
like was just i think loopy a couple
nights but i just definitely remember
her like
laughing insanely hard and like trying
to like i just remember going like this
a lot uh but i don't think she ruined
any tanks
um
i think anyone ruined any takes i mean
people ruin takes
dave ruined him with his acting
yeah yeah yeah that's fair
i don't know i mean
i i laugh i would laugh a lot in our
scenes together because oh my god david
and i were breaking nonstop
they're feel like i was always near you
guys while the scenes were happening and
it was
like
for dave and i were a lot of
face-to-face talking and like we
remember for seven months like if you
were not my wife or one of my daughters
and i was talking to you i was wearing
like a mask and like standing six feet
away
and then you go from that to like
dave franco like cleaning the inside of
your nose with his tongue and you're
just like this is my job this is what i
do for for work to feed my family
he's not kidding sadly he's not kidding
what did it taste like dave
it tasted great it tastes great
great
i keep my nostrils very clean i i
put a little cologne inside of them
for all
what's interesting about this i would
imagine you guys had to block shoot this
and playing multiple versions of the
same character possibly on the same day
um uh what was that actually like in
trying to keep it together in your head
we didn't have to do anything because
chris miller is so on top of it like he
just
very effortlessly will explain to you
okay so here's what's happening now this
is you know episode five this is alana
this is the horror beat
here's what happened the scene right
before this which we haven't shot yet um
like he was so on top of it and his team
uh his ad team and and the script
department were so uh on top of it that
we were allowed to come to set and
really just focus on trying to be funny
i feel like we should give a shout out
to uh the dp carl hurst who essentially
was
was just creating all these different
looks for the show every single episode
and i just feel like we don't talk about
carl enough the first time i saw like
the first time i saw dick and i saw like
what they were doing i was like
whoa this is like not like a sitcom this
is like like really like
looks like it is a michael bay movie
right yeah there's those quick there's
those quick clips of the black and white
kind of movie style i want to see the
whole thing like that like that looks so
beautiful
it does yeah
uh dave individual question for you um
uh so you directed somebody that i used
to know i believe you cast zoe uh but
not
and so i'm just curious i'm curious why
yeah i'm curious too dave let's let's
get into this a little bit thank you
it's a really fascinating question that
i'm very happy that you asked um
so i actually uh i knew ike was likely
just gonna turn me down so i didn't
wanna have to make it awkward for him so
i just like kind of surpassed that whole
that whole back and forth you know
always make the offer
always make the offer i was thinking
about you man i was just trying to play
it like you
ain't good
yes
[Music]
yeah
totally because you've never how long
have you been practicing that zoey zoe
you're gonna fight
um the reality is the reality is is i
was busy
during your shift so even had you
reached out have you shown me the
respect and been like hey we got this
part this is
janitor you won't stop masturbating we'd
love you to come play him
i would have been like brother i i'd
love to help you out i just cheated on
shooting stuff i got stuff but you
didn't even reach out yeah now you
really [ __ ] with zoey
playing the masturbating gym
that's pretty good that's pretty good
uh ike the question for you
one of my most anticipated movies of
this year is the nic cage film
unbelievable weight of massive talent
yes i could not be more excited for this
movie i know you're in it uh what can
you what can you say about being part of
it because for me it's it's really i
cannot wait
oh man it's so great he's i've been such
a fan of his for a very very very long
time and
uh you build up someone in your head
and then when you get to finally work
with them they're exactly what you
wanted you know
but he he uh he's
yeah man nick's playing himself and he's
playing himself going to spend a weekend
uh with like a
possible
cartel
type of guy and play by pedro pascal
and of course you know cia has to get
involved and it becomes a very big kind
of geopolitical firestorm and everyone
go
top three nick cage movies go i'm going
to raid arizona adaptation
adaptation um
i mean i
i part of me wants to go i think i'm
going to go bad lieutenant man i'd love
to wow
so much i thought that movie was like
yeah i loved it those are my i was gonna
say you gotta kind of throw in face off
though
face off my top face off my classic i'm
also a big con air guy like conair is a
really fun movie to watch which is
shockingly
not directed by michael bay
you know that i didn't know that i
always thought it was a michael main
movie but it's not it's just
like a michael lange
you learn something new every day saudi
and write down the wise things that i
was
pig is fantastic listen i gotta go i
really mean it uh congrats on the series
it's so good um thank you for giving me
your time brother thank you thank you so
much man really good question thank you
man